Hannah Montana's best friend a secretary
who's not impressed by ghosts and Mr
Incredible himself if the cast of Young
Sheldon looks familiar there's a good
reason why
the star of young Sheldon Ian Armitage
was only nine years old when the prequel
series premiered in September of 2017
but believe it or not this wasn't the
first time he appeared in front of the
camera years before the series Armitage
made a name for himself on YouTube
running his channel Ian loves theater
where he hosted a series of reviews of
stage plays and musicals like Hamilton
one of the most
tremendous amazing fantastic
better than fantastic shows ever gaining
some level of notoriety thanks to his
YouTube series Armitage made his
unintentional TV debut in an episode of
Impractical Jokers before getting
official casting calls his first came in
an episode of Law and Order Special
Victims Unit ahead of snagging rolls in
a string of 2017 indie films this
includes the last Castle our souls at
night and I'm not here while starring on
young Sheldon Armitage has had a
recurring role as Ziggy Chapman on big
little lies and his even done voiceover
work for cartoons like scoob and PAW
Patrol the movie
playing Sheldon's father George Cooper
senior is actor Lance Barber oddly
enough he actually made a previous
appearance on the Big Bang Theory as a
peer of Sheldon's in a season 5 episode
he must have impressed producers because
several years later he reappeared as
Sheldon's dad Barbara's very first TV
role came in an episode of ER and he
quickly made a career as a guest
starring actor across a number of big
name Productions this includes
appearances in episodes of Gilmore Girls
Californication and the detective comedy
monk in 2005 Barbara joined a Show's
main cast for the first time playing
Paulie in the Lisa Kudrow sitcom The
Comeback if you recognize Barbara from
anywhere though it's probably his
recurring role as Bill Ponderosa in It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia I was
drinking a glass of milk when you loosen
me up Bill I spiked the milk with
methylene dioxy pyruvalerone what is
basalt
every family sitcom needs a great mom
and young Sheldon has Zoe Perry as Mary
Cooper Perry can actually Trace her TV
career all the way back to the 1990s
when she played Jackie Harris in a pair
of episodes of Roseanne that Revisited
the Youth of its titled character this
is doubly ironic because the older
version of Jackie was played in that
series by Laurie Metcalf who also plays
the older version of Mary Cooper on The
Big Bang Theory oh did we mention that
Metcalf is Perry's actual mother Perry
would have to wait more than a decade
before her next TV appearance which came
in a 2006 episode of Law and Order
Criminal Intent she seemed to find a
niche in legal dramas though popping up
for single story Parts on Cold Case
deception and conviction over the next
few years before landing a recurring
role on the family just before starring
on young Sheldon Perry had closed out a
nine episode stint as political spoiler
Samantha Roland on Scandal
to play the role of Grandma Cooper
better known as Mima young Sheldon
Enlisted the services of 80s icon Annie
Potts who fans will probably recognize
from her role in the 1984 classic
Ghostbusters where she played cynical
receptionist Janine melnitz she'd come
back to reprise the role in 2021 for the
legacy sequel Ghostbusters afterlife 2.
in between of course Potts had a long
and successful career both on TV and at
the movies in cinemas you might know
pots for movies like Pretty in Pink or
the cult classic Whoopi Goldberg comedy
jump in Jack Flash on TV pot start for
Four Seasons on any day now between 1998
and 2002 before landing a recurring role
on Joan of Arcadia in 2004 other
recurring TV parts saw pots appearing in
four episodes of Law and Order SVU and
five episodes of Chicago Med while she
also had a role on the short-lived
Leslie Bibb comedy cgb in addition to
doing work for cartoons like the 2020
reboot of The Rocketeer and Johnny Bravo
Potts might be best known as the voice
of Bo Peep in the Toy Story franchise
Glenn you say I get someone else to
watch the Sheep tonight
while he's appeared in every episode of
Young Sheldon as well as a single
flashback episode of The Big Bang Theory
Montana Jordan's part as George Jr is
actually one of just two on-screen roles
in his career so it's not likely that
you'd recognize him from anywhere else
his other role though comes in the film
The Legacy of a white-tailed deer hunter
a 2018 Netflix movie from writer
director Jody Hill the film stars Josh
Brolin is a hunter named Buck Ferguson
who brings his friend and cameraman Dawn
on a weekend sojourn into the woods with
his son Jaden Montana of course plays
Jaden and while the movie didn't Garner
many positive reviews its cast is often
cited as one of its few bright spots
unlike her co-star and on-screen brother
Montana Jordan Reagan rewards resume
stretches back a bit further Beyond
young Sheldon beginning in 2014 when she
was just six years old that year she
made her television debut in an episode
of Modern Family and would go on to
reprise that role a season later in 2015
she appeared in an episode of the
Netflix series with Bob and David a
Revival of sorts of Bob Odenkirk and
David cross's 90s cable comedy Mr Show
with Bob and David from there reward
showed up alongside Lily Tomlin and Jane
Fonda on Netflix's Grace and Frankie as
well as on the similarly titled Alexa
and Katie any pots isn't the only Toy
Story Alum to have a major role on young
Sheldon the other is Wallace Shawn who
plays mima's boyfriend Dr Sturgis Shawn
a veteran character actor with an
unmistakable nasally voice gives life to
the ever frightened Rex in the Toy Story
films if you're a child of the 80s
though you probably know Sean best for
his role as the villainous Vizzini in
the Rob Reiner classic The Princess
Bride
level
s in the heart I don't think I miss what
you think it means Children of the 90s
however remember Sean as the lovelorn Mr
Hall in clueless he returned to the role
again for the clueless sitcom spin-off
which aired for three seasons sci-fi
fans will remember Sean best for his
recurring role on Star Trek Deep Space
Nine where he played the cantankerous
Grand Nega zek teens in the 2000s might
know Sean from his stint on Gossip Girl
other memorable roles in his career
include runs on Crossing Jordan The
Cosby Show and Murphy Brown
of all of the cast of the series Ed
Begley Jr might have one of the longest
and most prolific filmographies which
begins all the way back in the 1960s
with his acting debut in an episode of
My Three Sons over the decades he's
accumulated more than 300 credited roles
but we can try to give you a brief
overview of some of his most important
work after shooting to stardom with his
leading role on the 80s medical drama
Saint elsewhere Begley Jr spent the next
few decades appearing in various hit
shows and movies including The Love Boat
Roseanne and Third Rock From the Sun in
the 2000s Begley Jr continued playing
doctor roles on 7th Heaven as Dr
Hastings and on Kingdom hospital is Dr
Jesse James he also had the memorable
role of Stan's sitwell on Arrested
Development though we can't possibly
rattle off every part he's ever played
we couldn't let his bio be complete
without mentioning his role as Hiram
Gunderson on the critically acclaimed
Six Feet Under
Pastor Jeff often serves as the foil for
young Sheldon engaging the
scientifically minded Sheldon in some
surprisingly hard-hitting discussions on
science versus religion playing the
Quasi villain on the show is actor Matt
hobby who appeared on HBO's acclaimed
period crime drama Boardwalk Empire with
a recurring role in season 3 as Philip a
few years later he took a part in the CW
drama Heart of Dixie and not long before
he debuted on young Sheldon hobby held a
role on the Rob Lowe comedy the grinder
to most kids the phys ed teacher was
either the nicest member of The Faculty
or the meanest and fortunately for
Sheldon Wayne Wilkins is the former the
friendly and affable School coach in
fact Wilkins takes center stage in his
own story dealing with the breakdown of
his marriage while leaning on his friend
George Cooper senior for support he's
played by doc Farrell a journeyman actor
who counts Wilkins as his first ever
recurring role on television prior to
the series Pharaoh had only ever
appeared in single episodes of other
shows starting out playing mostly
unnamed background characters since
appearing on young Sheldon he's also
popped up in small roles on Curb Your
Enthusiasm and Arrested Development as
well as in an episode of the Revival of
Will and Grace
on young Sheldon Melissa Peterman plays
the role of nosy neighbor Brenda Sparks
the mother of Billy and Bobby who works
at the local bowling alley she's played
by Melissa Peterman who made her acting
debut back in 1996 as a background
character in the Coen Brothers classic
Fargo despite her cinematic Beginnings
peterman's career has been almost
entirely on television beginning with an
episode of Just Shoot Me In 2000. if you
recognize her though it's probably from
her starring role in the long-running
family sitcom Ariba with Reba McIntyre
where she played the religious Barbara
Jean heart if you watch country music
game shows though it's almost certain
that you know her as the host of the
singing bee a competition that tossed
together elements of karaoke and
spelling bee from there Peterman became
a villain host or a celebrity guest on
the game show circuit so you might
recognize her from episodes of home and
family and the 100 000 pyramid or
dancing fools just to name a few
young Sheldon has recruited its fair
share of 80 stars but there's still one
more Craig T Nelson who plays Dale
Ballard owner of the local sporting
goods store Ballard is also Missy
Cooper's baseball coach an appropriate
role considering Nelson is easily best
known for playing the title character on
the 90s classic sitcom coach prior to
coach Nelson had recurring roles on
Private Benjamin and was part of the
main cast of the crime drama Chicago
story in the 80s beyond that stretch of
success on TV though Nelson has also had
plenty of hits at the movies he starred
in Classics like Poltergeist Action
Jackson and Turner and Hooch in the 80s
following his run on Coach Nelson
appeared in The Devil's Advocate with
Keanu Reeves but while many audiences
May recognize Nelson's face from one of
his many famous films or popular TV
shows it's also his voice that might
stand out to you that's because in The
Incredibles and its sequel Nelson played
Bob Parr Mr Incredible himself
young Sheldon has seen its share of
surprising breakout recurring guest
stars and audiences were introduced to
another in season 5 with the arrival of
Mandy the older woman who George Jr
becomes smitten with she's played by
Emily Osmond sister of former child
actor and success star Haley Joel Osment
starting her career the same year that
the Sixth Sense premiered osman's first
acting job was in the film The Secret
Life of girls though it's more likely
you'd recognize her from her role as
Gertie Giggles in the second and third
Spy Kids movies but her biggest role by
far began in 2006 when she starred
alongside Miley Cyrus on Disney's iconic
series Hannah Montana as best friend
Lily Truscott from there Osment moved to
more serious fare starring in the
crackle Thriller cleaners in 2013 while
also doing voice work for cartoons like
kick butkowski and Rainbow Brite more
recently Osmond has had starring roles
on a pair of short-lived dramas almost
family and pretty smart as well as a
recurring part on Michael Douglas's the
Kaminsky method if you were a kid in the
late 2000s though you might also know
Osman for her music as she released an
album in 2010 and shot a number of music
videos to accompany it
foreign